thank you very very much everybody for
being here this afternoon and later on
this evening for what promises to be two
fantastic events in the life of Carnegie
Mellon University my name is Jared Cohen
I'm the president of Carnegie Mellon and
it really is a pleasure to welcome to
hear this maybe just this group might be
the largest Gallagher in Carnegie Mellon
has ever had in car kin in Silicon
Valley and when you're joined by all of
your compatriots and other alumni
attending the six o'clock event it
surely will be the largest gathering
Carnegie Mellon has ever had in the
valley that in itself is very very
exciting I'm my job as I guess you would
call me the setup guy or the warm-up act
in the business and I will do my job and
get out of the way very quickly here
you're going to get a taste of what
Carnegie Mellon is doing in Silicon
Valley something we are extremely proud
of and also excited about its effort
that started some years ago and I have
to say started under conditions that
simply don't exist today so this was pre
bubble bursting it was at a time when
NASA actually had a liquid budget and
they could fund some things a time when
companies in the valley were interested
in collaboration of universities and all
of that changed we should we soldiered
on as a word and in a way we're looking
at the rebirth or the second age of
Carnegie Mellon in Silicon Valley you'll
be seeing the special character of our
educational programs here our focus on
teaching by doing and you'll see some of
the exciting research that's going on
here I want to acknowledge Jim Morris
was sitting up here in the front Jim why
don't you stand up some people can see
it was Jim's bright idea to create this
in Silicon Valley and not only what is
it his idea but he was the founding dean
of this campus and the person who got it
going and who kept it going during those
interesting and challenging times I want
to thank Jim for his vision his
commitment and his trek tremendous work
for Carnegie Mellon on behalf of
Carnegie Mellon here in Silicon Valley I
would also acknowledge pradeep khosla
who doesn't have to get up because i'll
be getting up in a moment to speak to
you as jim was looking towards his
retirement the board of trustees in the
central administration wanted to find
another dean at the University who could
take over the administrative leadership
for the Silicon Valley campus and we
were so lucky that we determine for deep
who has done a fantastic job one of the
great things he did was to somehow coax
Martin risks into still not retiring and
serving as the new director Martin much
you stand up so you can see market risk
I really installed leader of our campus
here Martin thank you very much for
taking this on and I want you to know
what / deep and Martin know that the
board of trustees of the University and
the central administration to say the
present and the provost are committed to
this campus indeed the board authorized
that investment in our facilities in
order to assure the future of what we're
doing here so very excited very proud of
what's been achieved we think that
there's a fantastic future ahead it's my
pleasure to introduce
because lleva dean of engineering
Thank You Jerry you want to stand behind
me and hold me I have vertigo seriously
I don't know why there's a podium out
here on a podium right so well as Jerry
said I'm pretty close on the Dean of
engineering and I've been working with
Jim Mora's very closely for the last
year on this campus and revisiting this
campus over the last five years that jim
has been being there's a lot of great
things that have happened on this campus
and one of the two great things or one
great thing that has happened is if your
highway 101 carnegie mellon sign is out
there or how many of you saw that sign
maybe stanford has a sign i don't know
about that but I know Carnegie Mellon
has a sign and were it not for Jim you
know part of existing is being known and
that sign is really important to us
right we had significant programs out
here mainly masters and software
engineering masters and software
management that over the years have done
extremely well these are programs that
position is very uniquely visa be
existing universities out here who don't
quite operate at the same level as we do
in these niche areas and one of the
things we are doing in the process of
revision aid is expanding these programs
from just being part time to being full
time as we also think about revisiting
what we are saying or what we are
thinking about are doing is that this is
Carnegie Mellon's projection and Silicon
Valley and what that means is we are
going to exploit every possible
opportunity all the good things that
Silicon Valley has to offer and have our
students experience it and the best way
to experience it is to create what we
call bicoastal programs so if you're a
master soon right now and join
Pittsburgh you have the opportunity in
specific areas like mobility like
security to spend two semesters in
Pittsburgh and spent two semesters out
here and be immersed in this culture of
innovation this culture of
entrepreneurship I don't get me wrong
you know Pittsburgh also has a culture
and entrepreneurship but there's
something about this air that once you
start reading it you don't want a real
job anymore you want to be an
entrepreneur all right you you want to
use somebody else's money to create
something and maybe it becomes something
big or maybe you lose it but why not all
right but as we all know more often than
not it has become something big and we
want to be part of this environment so
right now we have several masters
programs and art that are bicoastal
programs in addition we've also decided
that this campus this location we is
going to do be violent research and all
the faculty out here when we both
teaching and research so we have just
created a center for mobility research
that Martin versus the director often
he'll be up in a second to talk about it
and last but not the least is a PhD
program with electrical and computer
engineering where these PhD students
spent two years in Pittsburgh and three
years out here that is assuming you can
finish a PhD in five years that's how we
advertise it the real number is like
seven or eight but but we don't want to
tell that to anybody right so five years
is what we call the average length of a
PhD program which by the way does not
exist it's less than the minimum to be
honest with you now having said that I
personally very excited about being here
a lot of faculty here and as you go
around you're going to be split into
groups and you will see the internals of
this building we have made significant
investments as Jerry was talking about
in building a state-of-the-art distance
education classroom we're building two
more we are going to have a lot of our
international students to our
international programs rotate through
the Silicon Valley campus and this
really has become especially for me as
dean of engineering the crown jewel for
college of engineering so I'm really
proud to be involved in this I'm really
thankful to Morton for having taken up
the challenge that he's going to deliver
on now and we
I'm gonna hand it over Martin thank you
very much see what he means about
vertigo and it's not just the podium I
was told I'd planned a long talk to tell
you all the wonderful things we doing
here and they said not a chance you get
a couple of minutes and that's it so
what I want to do is a little add my
welcome to that of Jerry and pradeep's
tell you I've been associated with
Carnegie Mellon here since its inception
I was actually at hewlett-packard and I
got started with chairman Jim kind of
inspired me to spend more and more time
and as they said I was about to a time
and I didn't and I was about to retire
and I didn't sound back and I'm really
looking forward to what we're going to
be doing over this next couple of years
we're moving to this next pages we
growing the programs you heard from
Pradeep from Jerry you know the
tremendous commitment we have the the
notion that we here right in the heart
of Silicon Valley that we're doing
innovative things in education in
research in entrepreneurship we want to
tell you more and go do this i'll be in
the tent after this and as you tour
around you'll see a number of the things
we do in robotics in hardware
optimization in smart environments in
wireless sensors and mobility and i
won't go into great detail about that
here you'll get a chance to hear me if
you want to after this what i really
want to do is sort of welcome you all
here you know this is your home here in
Silicon Valley and i look forward to see
you i look forward to interacting with
you I'd like to get your advice I'd like
to get your help we have now almost and
will
soon have 400 alums of this campus which
is really excited and we hope to see you
and these alums and other alums coming
here and saying this is our place this
is your home and really that's all I
want to say so welcome enjoy the tour
you'll see a number of the the faculty
will set up here and start out peace
here so thank you